ما زال الغموض بيحيط بمشاهد التسمم اللي
بترتكب بحق الطالبات الايرانيات في
المدارس من نوفمبر واللي زادت بشكل مهول
من ايام يعني في الاول كانوا كم حادثه
متفرقه والان عشرات المدارس ومئات
الاصابات اللي يصير تحديدا انه الطالبات
وهم ما داخل حرم الجامعه بيبداوا بشكل
جماعي بتظهر عليهم اعراض تسمم والكلام عن
انه التسمم بغاز في الجو مو معروفه طبيعته
بالضبط وبيتنقلوا طبعا للمستشفيات فورا
والاعداد جلسه يوم عن يوم بتزيد ايران
اليوم بتتكلم عن اكثر من 80 مدرسه و700
اصابه اليوم فقط
[موسيقى]
لليوم ما في اي اجابه واضحه من السلطات
الايرانيه عن المتورطين والمسؤولين وحقيقه
كما التصريحات اللي بنسمعه كثير ولكن
للامانه ما في اي احد قال مين هو المتورط
في هذه الحوادث اللي جالسه بتصير واحدث
التصريحات كانت للمرشد الاعلى ايه الله
خامنائي اللي طلع وقال انه هذه جريمه لا
تغتفر ويجب محاسبه المتورطين
كونان
سليم مهم اجر
ى افرادي
بغير غاب الاغمازيس
سردبين روبين
باشد مجازات
محكوم بجان تربو رينو اشد مجازات
وروايه الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي ما اختلفت
كثير عن خامنئي في ايادي واشخاص بتعمل هذه
القصه ومتورطه فيها ورئيسي قال انه اللي
جالس بيصير مؤامره من العدو وانها حلقه
اخرى من سلسله المؤامرات اللي يعني
بيحيكها الاعداء بهدف اثاره التوتر
والتهويل داخل المجتمع الايراني ونشر
الخوف بقلوب المواطنين وكمان كان طلع رئيس
السلطه القضائيه تعهد انه ما راح يتساهلوا
ابدا في معاقبه المتورطين وراح يعدموهم
ووصفهم بالفاسدين يعني مثل ما سمعتوا كل
تصريحات وعود بالمحاسبه ومؤامرات خارجيه
وداخليه ولكن للان ما في اي طرف خيط عن
الفاعل والجهه اللي بتسوي هذا الشيء لا
زالت مجهوله فالسلطه جلست توجه تهديدات
واعيد وهم اصلا مو عارفين مين ولا قادرين
حتى يوجهوا اتهم لاحد الا لايادي خارجيه
ومجهوله وهذا الشيء خلى ذوي الطالبات
يطلعوا طبعا في احتجاجات ويتجمعوا امام
مبنى وزاره التربيه والتعليم علشان من
حقهم يعرفوا ايش اللي جالس بيصير ولكن
السلطات الايرانيه بدل ما تقول لهم المفيد
واللي ممكن يريحهم اعتقلت العشرات منهم
وهذه الاعتقالات ما اوقفت الناس بالعكس
زادت من الدعوات مو بس لاهالي الطالبات لا
للكل علشان ينزلوا ويحتجوا على السلطات
اللي كثير من الناس غير انه بتحملهم
مسؤوليه استمرار حوادث التسمم في كثير
منهم جالسين بتهموا السلطات تحديدا انهم
وراء اللي جالس بيصير او الجماعات
المتشدده اللي تابعه لهم بالاساس
تنضم الينا السيلاوي الباحثه في الشان
الايراني من بروكسل اهلا فيك معنا منى
يعني صراحه اللي بيصير عجيب وغريب جدا هل
عندك اي تفسير او معلومات عن القصه هذه
تحياتي لك وللمشاهدين يعني صحيح انه
النظام يتضايق انه هو ضحيه وبالفعل هناك
ايادي خارجيه ومؤامره خلف هذه هي الاعمال
ولكن طبيعه النظام وتاريخنا مع هذا النظام
يدل انه هم خلف هذه القضيه وهذه الهجومات
واذا اذا كانوا بالفعل صادقين انهم يريدون
ان يعرفون من هو خلف هذا الاعمال لم
يكونوا
باعتقال الصحفي علي طبطبائي كور الذي هو
كتب عن قضيه التسمم في مدينه قوم النظام
قام باعتقاله يعني كيف يقولون نحن نريد
ان نحقق
ون باعتقال صحفيين
يحاولوا بهذا الامر
ايضا وعود باعتقال مثلا اشخاص المتورطين
في قضيه قتل
التي كانت حصلت في مدينه كرمان ومشهد اللي
كانوا يحبطلون من النساء اللي كان يمارسن
الدعاره ايضا النظام وعد وقدم كثير من
الوعود ولكن في النهايه على الرقم اصدار
حكم الاعدام قاموا باخذ رضايه اهل الدم
ولم يقوموا باعدام هؤلاء الافراد يعني على
رغم ان انا شخصيا ضد حكم الاعدام ولكن
هناك ازدواجيه معايير في قضيه التعامل مع
هكذا قضايا في حال نرى
استمر هذه الحوادث من ثلاثه اشهر حتى الان
لم يقوم باعتقال اي شخص في حال المحتاجين
اللي قاموا بحرق يعني سله زباله قاموا
باعدامهم يعني ليس
قبل كل هذه يدل انه هو النظام خلف وهذا
لانه النظام يتغذى على الازم
ات سيسبب لهم مشاكل بل لذلك يستمر مع
الازمات وهذه هي ازمه يعني مختلقه من قبل
النظام حتى يحاولون ان يسيطروا على شارع
الايراني بعدما عجزوا من خلال
القمعه من خلال طريق امنيه ان يسيطر على
الشارع المحتج في ايران ولكن يمكن لها رد
فعل عكسي او ادباك فايروس زي ما بيقولوا
لانه الناس برضو جالسين بيقولوا انه
النظام الايراني هو اللي وراها وبرضه
نزلوا باحتجاجات جديده يعني يعني يبدو
الاسلوب فشل
يعني يقول ممكن في احد المرات هذه الطريقه
نجح مع النظام الايراني ولكن في النهايه
الحالات الاجتماعيه الشعوب صعب بالنهايه
التنبؤ بهم ممكن واحد يتنبا انه نعم مع
هذه
هجومات ممكن الناس يتخوف ان لا يرسل بناته
الى المدرسه ان يجلس به
ولك حملاته ودعوات من الناس ان لا يتركوا
بناتهم ان يذهبوا الى المدرسه وهذا ما
يريد النظام الايراني ان يخلى المدارس من
الطالبات بلغت طالبات لانه هن من تمردنا
على النظام الايراني ونرى ايضا هجوم على
جامعيات يعني كلها يدل مدى سخط النظام من
تمرد البنات على قيم هذا النظام وعلى
وممكن ويكونوا هم النار هذه الصوره
فيريدون يحذفون النساء من هذا الحراك طب
الى متى النظام الايراني دائما كل ما
حيصير عنده شيء حيقول مؤامره خارجيه هذه
مؤامره خارجيه يعني بيدخلوا تحتها كثير
ناس يعني الصراحه
بالفعل كل كل الانظمه الاستبداديه هكذا
عندما يعجز ان يقوموا بما لازم يعني
يقوموه يقولون اما انها مؤامره خارجيه او
بسبب دول الغربيه اقتصاد الايراني منها
لدينا كثير من الاختلاصات كل يوم يخرجوا
او يعني بارق
او دول ممكن ان يس
موها ركنيه ضدها نحن بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كانت معنا منى السيلاوي الباحثه
في الشان الايراني من بروكسل شكرا لك
[موسيقى]